では五十六番目 アッパマットーアヤンガンドーヤーヤンタカラチャンドニ
ヨーチャシーラワタンガンドーワーティーデーヴェーシウッタモー
アッパマットーアヤンガンドーヤーヤンタカラチャンドニ
この  というのは すごく
まあ単純簡単で ヤーヤンタカラチャンドニというのは
まあインドにあったこの
せん センダンとかね チャラとかね
そういうあの 香りのあるものですね
とにかくその中でこのタカラというものはすごい香りのある植物みたいです
その高価な香りのある植物などのね
まあ花とかね まあセンダンなど
その香りっていうのはアッパマット
どっちかってアッパマッタっていうのは
あの そんなにどうったことはないっていう意味なんです
まあ量はすごく少ないんだと
ヨーチャシーラワタンガンドー
シーラワタンっていうのは道徳を守っている人の
ガンドーっていうのは香りは
ワーティーデーヴェーシウッタモー
ウッタマっていうのは
まあ崇高な まあ高度な
まあレベル高いの まあ神々のところまで届くんだと
天界まで届くんだっていうことなんですね
まあそれだけの意味なんですよ
まあ世の中にあるどんな香りよりも
まあ道徳的な人間の香りが
この道徳を守っているというね
その香りがどこまででも届いていくんだ
いくんだっていうこと
ですから まあこちらで
まあ説かれているのは
この まあしっかりした道徳
戒律とかね 戒めとかね
そういうものはちゃんと守っているならば
まあそれで大変性格的に香りのいい人間になるんだっていうことなんです
まあ仏教の道徳は まあだいたい皆様大変聞いて
まあプロになっていると思いますけど
あの明確なね すごい明確な道徳は
システムっていうのは仏教できているんです
ちゃんとわけがあって
こういう理由で こういうこういうことを守りましょうという事で
ちゃんと道徳を語られてはいるんです
いわゆるこの ただ単に闇雲に何か決まりを守るのではなくて
すごい理性や知識に基づいて判断に基づいて何かを道徳を守るという
道徳を守ることは 道徳といってもいろんなしきたり
習慣 いろいろなものを守るということは
大体人間の世界では大変人気あるというかね
すごい評価されています
誰でも何か特別なことをやることはね
すごいそれ自慢げにしては生きてます
インドの社会でもね もう激しく戒律
いろいろ決まり守る人々っていうのはものすごいたくさんいましたし
その人々の力もすごく強かったんですね
だいたい俗世間の人々は
一般の人々はもう何かを特定の何か守っている人のことを評価するんです
まあそれに乗って 自分のアイデンティティを何とかしようとして
いろんな決まりを守ったりするのは
普通の社会のどんな時代でも見られるんです
それで道徳は誰が決めるのかという問題にはなってくるんですね
だから自分が守る 規則はね
誰が決めるのかっていう
その時点でよく見られるのは
自分勝手に決めるんですね
ほとんどの場合は ほとんどの人々は自分勝手に
じゃあ私はこれこれするぞと何かを決めて守ったりはする
自分で決めたのに真面目に守るということは
それでもほとんどないんですけどね
では 自分にそういう何か決まり
守る決まりをね 規則を決める能力はあるのかっていうね
問題も出てくる だから自分のことをよく知っているならば
別に道徳なんか守らなくてもいいんじゃないかなということもありますけど
一応自分のことも知らないんですけど
私はこうします こうしますというふうに
だいたい一人一人が自分で自分の主観で道徳規則を決めて守る
守ってしまいます それなら道徳っていうのは各個人が決めるものであるとということになってくると
どうなるのかと 普遍性はなくなってしまうんですね
人は何するのかっていうのは他の人は知らないし
自由に自分好き勝手で何かすればいいっていうことになるんです
それでまた根本的な問題っていうのは
自分にとって一番いいことをね
自分が一番成長する ことっていうのは自分でわかっているんでしょうかと
自分に対して一番いいこと
これだと一番いい生き方
正しい生き方 これだとわかっているならば
人類の中で何一つ問題あるはずがないんですね
しかし 道徳を守る であろうとも
丸ない人であろうとも
人間っていうのは問題ばっかしでトラブルばっかしで生きているんですから
根本的に考えると分かってはないということは言えますね
だから自分にとって自分が何をすれば成長するんでしょうかと
大体それはわからないとは思います
しかし それに関係なく
好き嫌い 決まりとか自分で決めちゃうんですね
それで あまりわからないっていうことになってくると
みんな誰かの真似をする
どこかで自分の自由があって
私はあの人のやるようにやるんだぞとかね
いやいや この人をやるようにやるんだぞと決めたりする
その場合でも 自分の本意で
もう本意というか 好き勝手に決めるんだからね
結局は自分の判断になってるんですね
例えば ある人は大根の葉っぱとご飯しか食べてないんだぞと
すごいことですね じゃあ私もそういう風にやるぞと
で 決めてしまう場合はね
それでも正しいということになりませんし
なぜならば 自分勝手に決めるんだから
また もう一人の人がご飯全く食べないで肉だけ食べてきてると
それも一つの厳しい生き方なんですけど
野菜もご飯も何も食べない
もう何か肉だけ食べて生きていると
まあじゃあなんでその人のようにしないのかと
いうことでなってくるんですからね
やっぱり自分がいい あれよりはこれが正しいと自分が決めるんですね
もう一つ見えてくる問題は
何かこのちょっときついこと
厳しいことを やるということが世間では道徳として認めるんですね
簡単なことをやるのはあまり道徳だとは思わない
思えません 私はテレビを見るのはやめましたと
まるっきりもう見ないことにしましたと
処分しましたと するとすごいと言うんですよ
それはすごいことだと
私は何があっても 1 日 4時間テレビを見ることにしているんだよと
もし 1 日中忙しくて見ることできなかったら
徹夜してでもちゃんと 4時間見るんだよと
それは道徳として扱わないんでしょ？何をこれと
どちらにせよって難しいんですけど
だから道徳のビジョンというのは
まあそういうことで 私はちゃんと 3食食べることに決めましたよと
今日からはと 正しく 何て言いますか
行 何て言いますか 生活はね
規則正しく生きることにしました
何があってもきちんと 3食食べるそうと
素晴らしい方ですねとか
それは言わないんですね
逆に私はもう 3食やめて 1食にしましたよと
それってすごいと と決めてしまうんです
そこで何か基準があるんでしょうかね
で ある基準というのは
ただ何かちょっとややこしいことするんだっていうぐらいの話だと思いますけどね
だから 何かややこしい行為をすることで
道徳ということにしてやこう
そこはどんどんエスカレートするんですよ
それでそっちを断食する人だったら
もう他の人よりはそれで立派になるんですね
まあもっと山も毎月 1週間も山を登ったり下りたりするんだったら
もう何とか行と言うんですね
それも それまたすごい立派立派なことにするんですね
例えば  1 年間も人と喋ることをやめましたと
誰とも喋らないで黙ってるんだと
1 年間だ  1 年間も黙っていたんだと
すごい さすがな人だというふうに言ったりするんですよ
だから そこはエスカレートしたところで
この苦行というものは
世の中にありますよ それは人間の常識的な思考だから
この東西問わずどこでも同じなんです
ただ そういうことは まあ東洋でも西洋でも人間だからね
一応見られます そういうわけで
何かこの厳しい日常生活
楽に生きるんじゃなくて
何かちょこっと厳しいことをやるということは
すごい道徳になって教冒になるんですね
ヨーロッパではよく流行っているのは菜食主義っていうことなんですね
これすごいことやと もうとてつもない難しいことを自分たちでやっているんだと言って
えらい強引で で  ヨーロッパ人っていうのは
どんなくだらんことでも始めたら
必ずしもそれが自分たちが守るんじゃなくて
アジアやら他の国々の人々を守らなくちゃいけないんですね
だからすごい強引に恐ろしよ
もうもう脅迫で脅しで菜食主義になりなさいよと
で あなたの国で何人かというと
私と何人かしかないんだよということになりますけどね
まあそれはそちらの道徳で
我々は元々から完璧ですから
人に教えてあげる人をもう抑えておいて管理する仕事はもう白人の特権だそうです
で それでその真似をする人々も同じ特権でなんとか言ってやるぞと
日本の方々でもちょこっと半年ぐらい
あるいはヶ月間ぐらいアメリカに行って帰ってきたら
もう手に負えないんですよ
えらいこっちゃ もうみんなに指導するんです
ああしなさい こうしなさいと
で その影響を受けて 向こうでどういう生活するか
すごい惨めな生活をしていますけどね
何の立場もなく 別に旗を揚げているわけじゃないんです
誰でもそうなんですよ
みんなすごい惨めに生きてますよ
ヨーロッパの国々では
行ってみれば そのストレスをね
まあこちらでも発散するんです
だからそういう人々にとっては
もう菜食主義っていうのはすごい超難しい苦行で
になってるっていう それはどうったことないんですけど
そんなのはね でもまあそちらにしてみれば肉しか食わんだから
もう生まれた時からもうおっぱい飲むことをやめた瞬間からもう肉食べてるんだからね
まあまあクマやら虎やらね
それほど変わりはないんですけど
だから虎にしたっても草食べるっていうことはかなりきついんだからね
だから突然草食べ始めた虎が牛に向かって厳しい道徳を教えるんだったら
お前らね 生命いじめるんじゃないんだぞとかね
あれ牛も怯えてだから相手虎だからね
怯えて震えるんですけどね
何の意味もない話ですけどね
牛は元々草食べてたんですけど
だからまあ世の中の道徳というのはそんな程度だなと思いますけどね
だから自分にとっては苦しいんだったら勝手にしろよ
それっていうのはどうったことない人はいくらでもいるし
生まれつき肉魚食べなかった
食べないって人々も結構いるし
その人に向かって菜食主義語るっていうのはね
だからそれは今大体人気のある立派な道徳で
立派です とにかく西洋から来るものだからね
で みんな真面目に守った方がいいんじゃないかなと思います
で まだ色々はあるんですよ
そこでも白人でこのむちゃくちゃ南無妙法蓮華経と太鼓叩いたバカもいるんです
しかし迷信は大嫌いやと
自分たちはすごい哲学的で
もうインテリも真っ最中やと
で もうアジアなんかは迷信だらけで無駄に気持ち悪いと言いながらやってるんです
あれ アメリカの女性がボートガヤのところでお釈迦様の菩提樹をね
あのもう私はちょっと礼をしてお般若を手を挙げて帰ろうかなと思ったんですけどね
だからいつでも邪魔するんだから
とにかく人の目を盗んでサッと入ってみたんですね
ただ まあみんな同じ宗派がどうであろうとも
便所であろうとも 同じ仏教だから
何のことなくもう 本堂
本堂のというところの中に入って一番前に座っていたんですね
隣にすごいお年のおばあちゃんがいて
ティベット人の なんとか何とか呪文唱えてるんですね
で 顔を見たらもううるさいんですけど
やっぱりもう先はないおばあちゃまで
一生懸命 まあそれはそれで気分はいい
頑張ってくださいという気分になったんですね
それでもっと後ろに金属の鉢あって
それは繰り返して それにもう砂利を上からサラサラっとかけるんですね
またごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃに何か呪文唱えて
またサラサラと砂利を砂利ではなくてかけるんで
すっごいうるさい音なんですね
で まあティベット人が呪文唱えるのは自分たちの文化だからね
全然違和感がないんです
ずっとやってることだからね
この頭腐ってるアホが誰かと見たら
アメリカの女性なんですね
お前らもよくもバカもんでやるもんだなと
こんなことはと思ったんですけど
それがすごく気持ち悪くてね
もう途中でやめて もう他の人々は自分の文化だから
何やってもすごい全然違和感ないんですね
どうぞって感じで ちょっとそちらの場所を空けてあげて
こちらはこちらのことをやればいいんです
これ我々の偉大なる支配者たちが
指導者たちがそんなことをやるとね
やるのはいいんだけど
それこそ正しいとまた教えてくれるんですよ
である新聞記事で読んだんですけど
もうこれもアホが書いた新聞記事で
飛行機に乗ったら隣にアメリカのアメリカ人が座ってて
で あなたは何人などと話し合って
それでスリランカで出家を取って
そうするとそれで食事があげたら
この人はもうもらった配った食事を食べ始めたら
アメリカのすごくうるさくて
あれは嫌 これは嫌とかね
この人にもかかってきたんだと
あんた仏教でしょうと
仏教でなんでこんな肉とか魚食べるんでしょうかと
情けないんだと 私は菜食主義だよと
このバカのキチね 自分が仏教徒として恥ずかしくなったと
私は恥ずかしくなったんです
お前みたいなアホが仏教徒でっていうことはね
だから仏教でもない人いうことにすごく惨めに感じるんだったら
これは仏教徒じゃないんですよね
私なら簡単に答えますよ
何回もそういう 私もそういうことあったんですからね
あのね 私は差別はないんだよとはっきり言うんです
世の中を見ると とにかく何か言い訳して人をバカにするんだと
俺が肉は食わない あの連中肉が食うんだぞと
だから私は偉いという
そういう人間らしからぬ低次元の人って
いくらでも何のことなくむちゃくちゃ侮辱するんですよ
でも侮辱されているということで攻撃できないんです
一般的に喋ってるんだから
私の主義は何一つも差別をしない主義ですよと
で 徹底的にそれでもうもううまく話は進みますけど
負けたわけは一度もないんですけど
だからこの自分が何か道徳決まったのは勝手に決まって
それでもって人をバカにするというね
で それ一つ道徳になっています
で 聖者ぶるんですね 日本でもだいたい 10人に一人ぐらい聖者ですからね
それで犯罪を起こす場合は
犯罪加害者をすごく褒め称える
それは自分すっごく道徳的な
日本人はそういう立派な人って見せたくて見せたくて
あの 例えばあの女の子は自分のお母さん殺したんですよ
毒飲ませてね 私にはもうそれ
その事件だけはどうしても我慢できなくて
もう信じられないもう
実験するんだからね お母さんとすごくもう喧嘩して
ずっとお互いにいじめ合って
もう虐待されてあって
腹が立って殺したしまったというならば
それで理屈はわかりますけどね
そういうのは何もない
しかし 誰一人もそれはもう別に
どうとか その頭のいい子ですと
でしたとよく言うんですよ
子供が人を殺したら すっごく頭が良くて真面目で
もう今もまだ女の子 っていう機能かなね
その男の子はすごく真面目で
あの すごくいい人でしたと
こういう人って何言ってるんでしょうかね
だから他の真面目な子にも
まあじゃあ俺もやったってもいいんじゃないかなと思うでしょうかね
だって加害者を大事にするんだからね
まあだからまあ人間っていうのはもうそういうことでもう道徳世界っていうのはね
成り立ってないんで 無茶苦茶なんですね
自分勝手に何かいいと思って
それを実行しようとする
それ実行する自分がそれで立派であると
他人より優といてと で
それが汚い差別やということは全然気づかないんです
で 中部経典に経典が一つありますよ
私は嘘を言わない それで他の人々は嘘を言ってる
その人々は その人々は嘘
嘘を言う連中だと自分が思うならばね
それでは立場がないんだと
だから自分と他人を比べるということはね
差別につながるんです
で サリグッタなんかでは
そこは別な面でうまく使ってます
世の中は道徳を守ってないんだから
私一人だけでも頑張ってみようではないかと
自分のために 踏ん張るために使ったりする
それは差別するためじゃないんです
それは世の中の普通のことであると
それで私はそれで挑戦してみるんだというね
その中ではすごく優しさっていうのはね
他の生命に対してあるんですね
みんなやるんだから私もやるっていうことではなくて
誰もやってないんだから私もやりませんよという一般人を基準にしないことなんです
一般人を基準にしないで
一般人が別に知恵開発してるわけでもしてるわけでもないし
だからどういう生き方をするかっていうことはそんな定めてもないし
それにゴチャゴチャ言う権利もないし
それで悟った人の話を聞いて
その人を言うことはどうせ説く筋道はないことだから
では頑張ってみますということで
それで頑張ってみるためには
誰かの何かの応援がないと
励みがないと うまくやる気にはならないんだから
この道徳心がない社会を自分の励みに
応援に 自分を押してもらうために使うんですね
だからそこでそういう人々をバカにすることはできないんです
差別っていうのはすごい良くないことで
お釈迦様はすごい厳しく
厳しく批判されていることで
それでまあいろいろ道徳については言ったみたいんですけど
言ってないんですけど
たった一つのポイントなんですけど
道徳は個人が決める問題よと
個人が決めるものになってくると
いくつかの問題が出てくる
個人には知恵があるのかと
自分のことをよく明確に知っているのかと
明確に知ってるんだったら道徳なんか守る羽目にならんでしょうに
最初からもう完璧だからね
だからそれは一応論理的には成り立たないんですよ
子供は自分にとっては勉強することはとても大事なことであると知ってるんだったら
誰 何のことなくチャカチャカと勉強するでしょうに
上手くいってるでしょうに
だからあれこれやというふうな道徳規則設定する必要はなくなっちゃうんです
自分のことを知らないのにも関わらず
人間が何か規則を決めて頑張ってまいるんです
それで規則っていうのはすごいバラバラ
無茶苦茶で でお互いに別な規則を守る人は互いに批判し合ったりもする
そこに宗教 次にでは人に道徳を決めてもらうということになるんですね
では私で決めるんじゃなくて
人に決めてもらおうかなと ２
番目にそれはよくあるんですね
大体人がやってることはやると
人がやってることやるっていうことにも
あまり論理性っていうのは成り立ってないんです
もし世界の人々は完璧であって成功しているならば
人をいうことをやってもよろしいんですよ
しかし 世界を見ると そんな完璧な世界あるわけでもないし
うまくいってるわけでもないんですね
親言うことする では親が完全たる人格者というと
とんでもない話で 思ってないんですね
親個人の人生も であるならば
やっぱり人に聞いてもあんまり成り立たない話なんですよ
3番目に残るのは いわゆる伝統的で
文化的に何か決まってる決まりを守ろうということはね
その場合は個人差が消えちゃうんですね
親も伝統を守っているし
それは決まりですから
お前も守りなさいと子供にも言うし
子供にもこれは嫌やっていう権利はないし
なぜならばこれは大体文化で
誰でもそういうしきたり習慣守っていると
で その場合は 例えば一つの社会だったら一つの文化システムがありますから
みんな同じ規則などを守るようになるんですね
そうなったらどうなるかというと
それぞれの人間のグループ次第に道徳が変わってしまうんですよ
フランス人の道徳とドイツ人の道徳は似てないんです
イタリア人の道徳とまた似てないんです
それぞれ民族が違うんです
グループごとにも違うんですよ
イギリス人と比べてまた違うんですね
イギリス人とアイルランド人とまたえらい違うんですよ
微妙に もうえらいと言ったっても
それなりにしきたり習慣というのは違う
だからその組織の中で
そのグループの中で一定の規則を守ることになる
それが個人で決めるものよりも
親が言う道徳 大人誰か人が言う道徳よりも強いんです
その強さっていうのはどこから出てくるのかというと
明確なところは道徳を定めた個人がいないんです
例えば文化的なしきたり
習慣 誰が決めたんでしょうかと
ご飯食べて終わってごちそうさまでしたというのは
これ誰が決めたんですかね
知らないでしょうに これ文化なんです
誰が決めたことかさっぱりわからない
だから子供は私は嫌やっていうことは言えないんです
そんなこと言ったとしても
自分が大人になってくると
自分の子供にまた言うんだからね
ちゃんとごちそうさまって言いなさいよと
行儀悪いんだと だから文化的な
道徳 規則はまあかなり根付いてます
それが道徳かというと
大きな問題が成り立つんですよ
ではフランス人の道徳正しいか
日本人の規則正しいかと
ではそれぞれ別な生き方をして良いのかと
例えばインド人だったらものすごくまだ違うでしょうに
根が深く強いかもしれませんだけど
グループごとに規則が変わるんですね
だから私はすごい正しい道徳を守っているんだっていうことは言えなくなっちゃうんですよ
たまたま日本人で生まれたんだから
日本の文化的な道徳を守っていて
たまたまヨーロッパ人で生まれたんだから
こちらの決まり道徳を守っているだけでしょうし
たまたまインド人に生まれたんだから
インド的な規則決まり守っているだけなんですね
だから道徳として そういうことで文化的な規則決まりは根強い根深いかもしれませんが
あまり意味がないことになるんです
誰が決めたということでも全然ないんだから
なんでそんなことをやるのかという質問にも答えがないんです
そういうことですよ だからまあ
大変ややこしい問題なんです
社会人にとっては道徳っていうのは
面白いことっていうのは嘘言ってはいけないと何のことなく言うんだけど
なんで嘘言ってはいけないのかという質問を出されたら答えを持ってない
人のものを盗るなよと
なんで悪いんですか？と
そこは道徳のように見えるんですけど
それは道徳じゃないです
ただ文化を語っているだけ
日本の文化だったら人のものを盗るなよという文化なんです
それ言ってるんでだけであって
別に道徳を言ってるわけじゃないんです
だからなんででしょうかと聞かれたっても
言った人にとっては答えないんですよ
まあとにかくまあ社会的に言えば
文化的な道徳を大事にした方が
社会の安定と調和っていうのは成り立つんです
だから人は決してやってはいけないことっていうのは
自分の文化を壊すことなんです
壊しちゃうと その民族も壊れていく
管理できなくなるんです
だからなんですよ 西洋文化がずっと強引に人の文化を壊すのは
全く残酷で 人権 権利とかね
そんなのはもうクソ食らえという感じで我々に教えるんです
権利を守りなさいと言いながら
向こうはもう守らないことは向こうの権利なんです
で なぜかというと 文化を壊されたらもうどうにもならなくなっちゃうんです
だから今世界中すごい落ち着きがないのはね
そういうわけで この自分たちが何人かということはしっかりした方が
そこであなたと違いますよということで
なんとかうまくいくんです
もともと道徳はないという立場で私は喋ってますけどね
道徳はない立場ないと立場という立場では喋っても
やっぱりそれでも人間がお互いにトラブルを起こさず
問題を起こさず 調和を守って生きるということだったら
もう助けになるのは文化的な決まり
習慣になるんです それを喜んで自分で壊すと
いろんな違う文化の真似をしちゃうと
結局は自分の足場が壊れてしまう
[笑い]それもいろいろ理由があってね
経済的な理由やら政治的な理由やら
ただの単なるコンプレックスやらね
いろんなことでみんな自分の文化の土台も壊してはいくんです
それは即席のレベルで
だからといって文化的な土台ってどうったことはないんですね
たまたまそうなってるだけの話で
それも道徳にはならないんです
次にあるのはもう 4  4番目なんですけど
この宗教という この権利を持っている
オーソリティーを持っている組織が現れてきて
汝らにこうと道徳決めるぞという態度で道徳を一方的に決めるんですね
そういうオーソリティーを持っている宗教の場合は
もう思考パターンが人類だからね
決まってるんです だいたい上の人は下の人を抑えるという法則だと
親は子供をもう踏み潰して管理する
親をまた別な上の人に踏み潰されて管理されていると
考え方で来た途端もういろいろもうグループリーダーがいて
グループリーダーはグループを抑えている
原始時代のグループリーダーっていうのは一番人殺し屋で残酷な人なんですよ
王様っていうのは最高司令官でしょ？軍隊の
昔はそれは本物でしたね
でしたし 一番軍隊のトップは王で
だから戦わせてるとか
王ってかっこいいんだけど
昔はただの人殺し屋のヤクザグループなんですよ
そこでグループ作って
周りの人々は潰して殺して脅して抑えて管理する
で 私の国やっていうことになるんです
さらに凶暴な人々を集めて
さらに広げていくというね
そこはシステム化しているんだからといってかっこいいわけじゃないんですよ
ちゃんとした軍隊があるんだと
軍隊にもちゃんとしたしきたり決まりあるんだぞとか
何がそれと 軍隊っていうのは人殺すグループでしょうに
人殺すためのしきたり決めたって
何が道徳ですかね 例えば降参した人は殺さないよとか
捕虜になった人々にはちゃんと面倒見てあげてくださいとか
すごい道徳のことを語るんですね
だからいかにどのように人を殺すのかというぐらいの話なんです
だから野蛮的なところは直ってないんですよ
ただ 何か組織になってくると
人間っていうのは無知だから
システム化するとかっこいいと思っちゃうんです
それで社会ではそうやって恐ろしい人が人を平気で殺される人々っていうのはリーダーになっていて
すると王様になっていて
王様だったらどんな人を殺しても大丈夫でしょうし
昔はね 打ち首だと言ったらもうどうしようもないんですよ
独裁政でね そういう歴史ですから
人類の歴史はね だから何か考えると違うことは考えることできませんよ
我々は考えるのは我々知っている情報から考えるんです
知っている情報でなきゃどうやって考えるんですかね
それで出てきたのはこの最高権力者というね
王様よりも権利誰にあるのかと
そこで そのそのグループの中で最高権力者ということを設定して
妄想して それ人間作るんですよ
それでその考え方を作った人が道徳を決めるんです
これは最高権力者の言葉ですと
汝らこれ守りなさいと
文句言うなよと 文句言うことはできんと
だからこの独裁政権のモデルなんですね
絶対的な神っていうのは作ったのは
いわゆるヤクザ親分の方程式公式なんです
マフィアの公式なんです
マフィアっていうのはファミリーという単語を使ってますからね
だからすっごく憐れみ
慈しみを持っていて 人のこと心配する立派な人なんです
そういうイメージなんです
作るのは そのように絶対権力者である神も
もう慈悲に溢れている神で
でもあなた方は殺すんだよと
そういう調子なんです
一応人間好き勝手に道徳決めることはそれで強引に抑える
みんな同じシステム守りなさいということになるんです
それで何がなくなるのかというと
人の自由ということはそこで完全に失ってしまうんです
それで言われる通りに生きてみると
奴隷化するんですね 一応奴隷になった人はやることは道徳かと
奴隷に二日間に一回しか食事くれない場合は
その奴隷その食事食べるしかないでしょ
二日間に一回しか食事くれないんです
だからその奴隷は 私は二日間に一回しか食べませんよ
立派な人です 全然話にならないですよ
そういうわけで ただ強引に抑えられて
脅されて こうしなさいああしなさいと言われたところで
隣人愛しても道徳になりません
怯えてやってるんだから
だから結局４番目には世界の各人が勝手に道徳を作ることも
もうそちらに周り 誰か誰かから聞いて道徳を守ることも
文化的に自分の決まり規則を守ることの問題も解決したんです
解決したことしたいんですけど
結局全て壊しちゃったんです
人間を奴隷化しちゃったんです
だからなんで？という質問をする権利さえもなくなった
親が嘘をつくなと言ったら
なんで親には聞けますけどね
お母さんも嘘ついているでしょうというふうなことで
お互いにいくらか自由がありまして喧嘩できますよ
反論もできるし それがなくなったんです
なんででしょうかという質問は聞いてはいけない
それ聞いたら処刑で もう宗教を侮辱したことで
神を侮辱したことで 極端な罪になるんです
だからどうにも自由がなくなって
そう決まってる通りに生きるしかないんだぞというと
それでは道徳は消えたということなんです
そういうわけで まあまた決まり規則はまあ政府も作りますけどね
まあその場合はまあまあ自分たちの利益を考えてね
国民の利益ではなくてね
政府を安定するためにいろいろ決まり
法律っていうものを作って
それっていうのはあんまり道徳的な問題として扱う必要はないので
どうせ法律で裁きますから
これは守るしかない 自由はないんで
その場合でも 法律で決めたら守るしかないんですよ
破ったらもう捕まります
だから法律で定めたものを守っ守ったっても道徳になりませんよ
脅しですからね 例えば交通ルールを守っているんだって
誰がそれすごい道徳的な人間だと思うんですかね
我々は日本の法律をちゃんと守ってきている立派な道徳者ですよと言えないでしょうね
こんな誰でも守らなくちゃあかんでしょうに
文句言えんでしょうに
勝手に破っちゃうと もう捕まりますよ
あるいは政府はいろいろ汚職しているんだから
私は税金を納めませんよと
そんなのできませんよ
いくら汚職したっても
いくらやばいことしたっても
政府こちらは税金を納めなくちゃいけないんです
もっと頑張ってくださいと
だから そうやって強引に一方的に決める決まり
決めている決まり 守ることは道徳にならないんです
だから この一神教を作った人々は
それは適期過ぎてないんでしょうかね
それで神に決めたことを守って道徳であるならば
国の法律守ることも道徳になるんです
大体これぐらいですよ
社会のシステムは それで終了しますけどね
次に残っているのは この現代に現れてきた
このいい加減な民主主義と
いえ 平等主義やといういい加減な
全くの平等がない共産主義とね
全くも民衆の意見問わない
聞かない民主主義と まるっきり人間平等に扱わない平等主義の共産主義しかないんですからね
どちらでもいい加減でしょ
成り立たん この世界っていうのは
人間の頭でいくら考えたっても
では 共産主義の世界では労働者随分喜んで生きていたんですかね
随分搾取されただけでしょうね
権力者に では 民主主義だからといって一般人の意見通っている？通ってないんです
いかにバカに騙されるかって
騙された方が 騙し上手な人が政権取っちゃうんです
だから 物事を理解判断できない
知識能力はない 考えたくはない
怠け真っ最中で もう俺さえ良ければいいやという人間の間では
民主主義は成り立たないんですよ
民主主義っていうのはすごい理解能力があって
物事をしっかり判断して
そんな言っただけでは信仰しない
信じないとかね そういう超エリートの人類がいるならば
民族と言わなくたって民族なんです
知識のどん底にいる人間の世界でね
成り立ちません だからどちらにしたっても
まあまあそんなことで
だから最後に残ってるのはその二つ
それはあまり道徳の話にはあまりもう引用しなくたってもね
共産主義は何やとかね
資本主義が何やとかね
言ったってどうったことはないんですからね
どちらでも どちらでも崩れるということは決まってるし
お釈迦様は社会っていうのは崩れるものやと
ずっと崩れて崩れていくんだと
そんなもんでしょう それで例えば一神教があったら一神教で聖書があって
聖書で言うことはそのまま守ることは決まってますよ
守るべきであるということ
なのに宗派作るんですよ
解釈して自分の 自分の解釈して宗派作った途端
自分の意見なんです もうとっくに侮辱しているんです
本人は だからキリスト教のものすごい宗派があって
イスラム教にも宗派があって
どんなもう宗派 仏教にも宗派あるでしょうね
全て解釈なんです だからもうブッダの教えじゃないんです
結局が崩れるんですよ
宗派同士で喧嘩し合ったり
例えば聖書では苦行しなさいという一言どこにもないんですけど
結構苦行しますよ 神父さんたちはいるのは宗派が違う宗派によってね
それってどこを誰どんな権限でやっているのかというと何もないんですよ
誰かのアホが決めたことをまた次の人もやっていくだけの話で
だから崩れるんですよ
壊れるんです それであの文化的な根深いんだからね
いくら宗教でこれを潰そうと思ってもできない
だからアフリカ人のキリスト教の人々とヨーロッパのキリスト教の人々のやり方は違うんです
特にカトリック教会はとにかく文化をとことん壊そうってすごい狂暴でやっていたんですけどね
残酷に人を殺したりまでいろんなことをして
やがてカトリック教そのものが嫌になっていったところで
やっぱりそれぞれ文化もいくらか大事にしましょうということになってしまったんです
自分の国のケースで言うならば
結婚式っていうのは仏教の国なんですけど
二人でやることは全然しない
その代わりに その各家で誰かの年上の人が結婚式をやるんです
みんなお互いに尊敬している先輩の方
誰でも すごくそれで気分がいいんだよ
自分知ってるおじいさんとかね
日本でも誰か決まるでしょう
誰？なんて言います？あれは何人？うん
こうでしたっけ？披露宴に誰かいるでしょう
人が新郎頼んで 仲人 仲人ですね
仲人というものは 大体自分たちがいくらか尊敬している人なんですよ
そんな感じで 自分の国だったら
その二人といった一人が全部式をやるんです
その時でも結構現金でやるんで
これカトリック教から見れば
何やこれと この野蛮人のやり方と
自分たちはすごい教会で神父さんがやってるのではないかと偉そうに思ってるんですが
誰もそちらに行かないんですね
文化壊したいって壊れて自分の足元壊れてる人々は行きますけどね
行かない あれほど派手な教会があって
派手なカティナがあって
すっごいお金使ってるのに
結婚式はあまりにも惨めなんですね
それでそちら考えたのは
この私たちは子供たちがこの結婚式の時
祝福してやる経典を歌うんですよ
お坊さんが全然行きませんだけど
大体女の子グループがもう音楽的にそれを歌うんです
これが決まり 節も全部決まってるんです
これがまあ子供覚えているし
大人も知ってる それもう歌ってくれるとすごい気分がいいんですね
教会は何したかというと
自分たちもそうやって歌を作ったんです
それをまるっきり同じメロディで
同じ音楽で やるんです
雰囲気作ろうと 同じやり方で
女の子にすごいおしゃれをさせて並んでもらって
新郎新婦を祝福してということで
ということはどういうことかというと
やっぱり崩れるってことなんです
あんな強引に何か文化を壊して
自分たちの神の教え 神の道徳で抑えてやろうと思っても
やっぱり文化の根が強いんですよ
だから韓国人はもう九十五パーセントキリスト教でしょうし
すごい宣伝がうまくいったんです
で キリスト教でなきゃ学校に入ることもできないし
韓国ではね しかし 韓国人のキリスト教は韓国的ですよ
日本では私が知ってるもう東大の教授でしたけどね
カトリック教の人で で
子供が生まれちゃって
結局はどこでしたっけ？神社にお参りに連れて行ったんです
偉そうなこと言ってますけど
もう東大の教授だからとか
そういうのは全然相手にしてなかったんですけど
まあ昔ちょっと駒場にいたんだからね
よくそっち渡ったりもするし
で 私はそういう文化的なことをいろいろおしゃべっていたんですからね
あれもそれなりのやり返しで
まあやっぱりそういうことで
私もやっぱり子供をお宮参りに連れて行ったと
これキリスト教から見ればとんでもないことなんですよ
邪教の習慣だからね 私はそれは良かったと
文化ってのは大事ですよと言ったんですけどね
まあ結局はそんなもんなんです
ていっと悪いっていうことじゃなくて
うまくいかないんですよ
やっぱり 壊れます それで個人が何か私はこう思いますよという道徳的な思考が来ると
それまたそれによって変わってしまうんです
だから一神教みたいなすごい強烈な権威があって
道徳は汝らはもう殺すなかれ
嘘をつくなかれ 隣人を愛しなさいとかいうふうに呪戒が出ても
呪戒は呪戒で溺れてしまうんですよ
迷子になるんです で まあそういうすべての問題で一応ありましてね
だから道徳って何や？ということでね
お釈迦様になってくると
もう完全にこれは智慧に基づかなくちゃいけないと
法則を見事に発見した人が幸福に至る道を知っているだと
これ科学の世界でも法則を発見した日
発見しているんだからこそ科学を発展できるでしょ
発明できるでしょ 例えば電気ってなんぞやと
その法則を発見すればするほど
あらゆる電気機械が現れてきたんです
今はもう全て電気そのものでしょうに
我々の人生は インターネット使ってるんだぞとか
あれやこれやとか言った
全て電気だけなんです
電気文化 ただ電子あっちこちいじってるだけの話
それで電子の法則を知ったんだからこそ
コンピューター作られたんですよ
扇風機も冷房 暖房も作られたんですね
それで我々楽になっているんです
だから 科学発展によって人間が幸福になったという推測で
もう仮定で喋るならば
科学者には人間を幸福にする
楽にする方法を知っているんです
医学者には人間の病を治す方法論を知っているんです
ということになるんです
だから我々は病気を治すためにどうすればいいかというとお医者さんに聞かなくちゃいけない
何か何か機械が欲しければ
それなりのエンジニアにその頼まなくちゃいけないです
なぜならば法則を知っているんだからなんです
では 人間幸福になりたければ
知っている人に聞くしかないでしょう
心の法則を全部知り尽くして発見した人にのみ
あんたこうこうしなさいよと
そうするとこうなりますよということが言えるんです
だから 道徳を定める権利は神にないんです
ブッダにあるんです 究極な科学者だから
心の だから科学だから
では勝手に変えてみなさいと
どうなるのかと 無茶苦茶になるんですよ
例えば我々コンピューター買ってきて
自分好き勝手なことをすると動かないでしょうに
だから言われる通りにやりなさいと言われる通りにやると問題はないんだと
で そういうことで 方式は方式というか
法則は法則だから そこで一貫するんです
バラバラにならないんです
インド人がパソコン使っても
日本人がパソコン使っても
同じやり方で使うしかないでしょ
インド人だったらマウス使ってあかんとかありえないでしょう
またプログラム同じで
ただ言語っていうのは上乗せだけですよ
裏のプログラム全て同じですからね
そこはもうきちんとした法則に則ってできているんであって
たとえインド人であろうか
アフリカ人であろうか
もう何人であろうが パソコン使うんだったら同じやり方で使わなくちゃいけないんです
車を運転するんだったら
その同じ決まりで運転しなくちゃいけないんです
それで全部科学の世界では一貫しています
例えば注射する薬がある
それは直接血液に注射しなくちゃいけないと
ある患者さんにそれを飲ませるということはありえないでしょうに
飲んでも大丈夫と 飲んでも大丈夫じゃないんですよ
直接血液に入れる薬は
どんな人間であろうとも直接血液に入れなくちゃいけないんです
もし飲む薬は注射しちゃうと死んじゃうんです
もうそちらに科学できてます
的にできているんだから一貫しています
だから仏教ももう純粋なもう科学ですよ
これ 心の科学だけってそれだけ違いますけどね
物理科学ではありません
心の科学 それでしっかりした道徳システムあります
それ守るしかないんです
文句言う権利はないんです
しかし 守るか守らないか
自分自由 パソコン買うか買わないか
それ知った問題ないんですよ
パソコンもテレビも電話も買わないで
電気も引かないでいることは人間自由ですよ
しかし 楽になりたいと
ろうそくじゃなくて もっと明るい光で夜を過ごしたいと思うならば
電気引かなくちゃいけない
それだったら決まり守ってもらわないと
同じ決まり 誰でも守っている
守らなくちゃいけなくなるんですね
そういうことで 仏教では道徳きちんと決まってます
しかし 人間の自由を奪ってないんです
世界中人類が決まってる道徳を守らなくちゃいけないんだけど
一神教をやったような大失敗をしてないんです
自由はあるんです 守るか守らないかっていうのは個人の自由で
それで楽になりたければ
もうこの決まりによって守らなくちゃいけない
いえ 嫌やというならば
それはそれでという それで現代日本で一人の人がもう電気も大嫌いというならばね
電気機械も大嫌いというならば
日本人あるいはもう味わっている楽しみも便利さも何一つもその方にないでしょ
炊飯器もないんだからね
電子レンジもないんだからね
そういう生き方決める権利はあります
その分結果も決まっている
そこだからお釈迦様が言うんで幸福になりたければ
その条件付けて幸福になりたければ
これこれこれこれ守りなさい
守りなさいと言うので守るものであると
なぜそう言うのかというと
知っているんだからと
そこで智慧の世界だから
なぜという質問に答えているのです
ブッダ以外誰も答えていないんです
神に人殺す権利あるのに
なんで我々は人殺しではならないのかということは成り立ってないんです
だからなぜっていう質問に釈尊がきちんと答え出して語ってはいるんです
それで道徳は基準っていうのは人間にも考えればわかりますよと
真理だから誰でも調べれば同じ答えに来るんだよと
そういうことで 一番分かりやすいことは
自分のためになること
周りの人々のためになることと
普遍的に誰の生命のためになる
役に立つ 幸福になることも一貫して道徳ですと
たったその一行で全て解決していますよ
だから道徳守ることはもう決まってもう断言できますね
ありがたいことであると
文句言うなよと 一切の生命のためになることをやってはいけないという話ないでしょうに
そんなこと言っていられないでしょうに
しかし 自分のためになるだけだったら危ないんですね
周りにどうなるかわからない
だから周りにもどうなるのかと調べなくちゃいけない
周りだけではまた危ないんです
第三者にどうなるかわからないんですからね
それで自分にも周りにも第三者にもためになるものだったら
もう極端に完璧な道徳行為ですと
それをやると幸福になるのはもう決まっていて
当たり前の法則ですと
で ごちゃごちゃ文句を言うなよと
文句言えませんだからね
例えば人を殺してはならん
では生命を殺してはならんと
自分が喜んで殺すかもしれない
相手の生命にはためになってないでしょうね
相手の生命立場から見れば極端に悪いでしょうね
殺される側にとっては
はっきりしてもうそれは不善だよと
だったら では 動物であろうが
ちょこっと餌あげることはね
あげること それはいいことやと
なぜかというと その動物はそれで助かっているんだからね
飢えている猫がいる ちょこっと餌をあげると
猫がそれを喜んで食べると
それは猫が助かるでしょうね
ためになってます だからそれが明らかに道徳なんです
それほど難しくないんでしょうと
ブッダの話をもうカニングして喋ると
すごい簡単に聞こえるかもしれませんだけど
人類にはもう作ることはできなかったっていうことは
ずっと延々と喋ったのはそういうわけなんです
これほど哲学者 これほど宗教家たちが
これほど知識人がいて
道徳設定することできなかったんです
一人にも ギリシア哲学から現代アメリカ
イギリスの哲学者っていうのはすごいいるでしょうに
では何か道徳を言えるのかと
日本で有名な哲学者の先生がいてね
昔若い時はもう徹底的にヨーロッパの実存主義好きになっていたんだと
それこそすごいと思って
またやがて諦めたと で
仏教になったと あれほど国際的に認められていると
哲学者なんですけど 仏教徒になったって
まあ何か阿弥陀様を信仰しているだけなんですけど
いや なんだこの頭と思ったんですけどね
それ矛盾持ってるんだからね
いい加減目覚めてほしいんですけど
まあその程度ですよ 世界的な哲学者といってもね
立派な方ですよ だから実存主義とかなんとか
これ格好いいやとしがみついたって何もないんですね
結局は だからこの軽々く
なんだ仏教分かりやすい
これは単純明快でとかね
そんな貶すもんじゃないんです
人類でできなかったことなんです
随分簡単単純で解決してみせているんです
それで心の法則で次に語るんですよ
幸福を目指すものはという
あるいは自分を愛するものはという自己愛
これっていうのは実感でしょう
否定できないんです いかなる生命でも自分を自己愛やります
自分のことを大事にしているんです
だから道徳っていうのは絶対的で否定できん
自己愛するならば これこれこれしなさいよ
このバカって調子なんです
あなたにはそういうごちゃごちゃ言う権利はないんだと
だって自己愛あるでしょうにと
だから自己愛っていうことも
自分の幸福を目指すとか
同じ単語の同義語ばっかりですけどね
自分の生命の生き方を法則的に見てみると
生命っていうのは自分の存在を意識して自分の存在を守るという
その中心で世の中を見ているんです
人間関係も家族も結婚も何でもかんでも自分のためにやっているんです
子供を作ること 妊娠することは知らないんですけどね
みんなの権利とは管轄と違いますけど
認識したところですぐそこはもう自分のために変えるんです
私に子供がいる 家族がいると
それから必死で子育てする
それは自分のためにやっているんです
もし子供が何でも自分に幸福
安らぎ 楽しみ 期待 何も与えてくれなかったら
もう簡単に殺すんです
簡単に事が起こるそうです
だから結局は偉そうなことをみんな勘違いして思っているだけで
全て自分のためにやっているんです
それ認めないんだからおかしいんです
平気であなたのためにやっているんではないかと
平気ですごい嘘ですけど
旦那に喧嘩する時でも
私はずっとあなたを尽くしていたんではないか
冗談じゃないんです 自分の利益なかったらすぐその場でもうやめるんだから
だからうまくいってないんですよ
だから子供にでも何か言う場合はね
あなたのために言っているって言っても
子供はあまり気にしないんですよ
そうじゃなくて お父さんすごく楽しいな
君はそこ行ってもう試験しっかり勉強するんだったらね
お父さんお父さんうるしくてもうしょうがないんだよと言うと
やりくになるんですよ
本当のことを言っているんだから
あ そうかそうか あんた楽しいか
じゃあ勉強してやるぞと
あなたのためではないかとかね
だからちゃんとこの真理認めないんだから問題が起きてあって
だから真理として言えば
この自己愛ということは真理であって
自分のことは何よりも大事にするという
いいえ 私は私の命より子供の命が大事です
そんな嘘でしょうに だってなんで中絶するって言えるんですかね
それ人殺しでしょ いろいろ理由をつけちゃって
育てる権利は能力はないとか
あるいはまだ結婚していないとか
まだ学生だから中学生だからとか
いろいろ理由つけちゃって
家族にとっては恥ずかしいやとか
すべて自分のためでしょうに
で 生命殺すんですよ だから仏教から見れば
その被害者にとっては最悪なことなんです
だから非道徳になります
不善悪行為になります
自分の苦だけ見たんです
他人の苦は考えなかったんです
だから自分の損得だけではなくて
周りの都合も第三者の立場からも考えてくださいと
それで純粋な道徳項目になるんだと
だから ある立場では 仏教では項目決める必要はない
ただ方式だけ守れと 方式守って自由に生きてみなさいよと
そうすると社会が変わっても変わっても
時代が変わっても変わっても
公式は同じだから そこで何をすれば自分のためになるか
何をすればもうすべての生命のためになるかということをその都度その都度判断できる
で 公式だけずっと一貫して繋げるんですね
例えば昔なら夜なんかはあっちこっち行くなよということは言えるし
今は別に時間もどこ行って誰がいたっても
もうあまり関係ない社会に変わっているんですね
夜歩くことは非道徳やと言っちゃうと
それは今無効になっているんです
項目的に見ると しかし公式で見ると
そういうことはないんです
当時では夜歩くことは他人に迷惑し
自分にも危険が来るし
今でも自分に危険が来ることをやるなよということで
だから自由がありながら
公式だけで道徳決まって決まっていることはできます
しかし お釈迦様は人間のことは全然信頼していないんです
もうどうせバカでやるって人が決まってるんだと
そんな自由に決めてくださいって言ったってもね
一つも決められないんだよと
観察はしないしね 考えてはしないし
だから本来人間とは何一つも判断できない
結論出せない もう感情的で
もうどうにもならない人間であると知っているんだから
ああいう自由を与えながらしっかりした項目を作るんです
これこれこれこれやと
道徳はと だからもう完璧に語られてます
知識的に インテリ的に
もう自由を守って公式でやりたければ
はい どうぞと 私は頭悪くてもう考えられませんでなければ
だったらこのセット守りなさいと
どちらでも同じやと たとえインテリが
究極なインテリの人が決めてもこれですよと
一人で決めても 一人で決めるぐらいは面倒くさいと思うならば
それで守ればいいですよと
それでインテリともそうでまるっきりない人も同じレベルに持ってきたんです
すごい極端なインテリの人は厳密に心理的に物事を考えると
生命を殺してはならないということしか出て答え出てこないんですよ
人間だけ殺すなよとか
こんな話にならんでしょうに
イギリス人ならペットをいじめるのはえらい凶暴ですよ
しかし キツネ狩りは禁止だったらまた暴動起こすんです
キツネは殺してもよろしいんだけど
犬なんかちょこっとこらこの犬と言ったら終わり
もう大変なことになるんです
もう笑っちゃいますよ
このもう変な思考はね
だからちゃんとインテリ的に考えちゃうと
まあ生命は生命でということになるんです
だからそんな難しいことを考えることできなかったら
お釈迦様は殺生するなかれと教えているんだからね
それ守ればいいでしょう
盗むなよと 簡単です 悪し様な行為するなよと
嘘言うなよと 噂言うなよと
悪口言いないと 異常な欲と怒りを納めなさいと
常識的な欲と常識的な怒りは
まあそれは修行によって絶つものですからね
邪見持たないよと その項目で完璧な道徳なんです
それにはなりません 興味もなりません
以上です で またそれをさらに根本的に
それからなんで道徳守らなくちゃあかんかというと
やっぱり不幸になるんだからでしょうし
それ知ったら誰でも道徳守るでしょうね
幸福になるんだったらね
でも守れないっていう現象があるんですね
幸福になるんだったらもう何でもするでしょ
川にも飛び込むんだから
冬なのにこれで万病に効くんだぞとかね
商売繁盛できる それ言っちゃえば
人間そういうものなのに
なんで幸福になるっていうことを教えてあげても道徳を守れないっていうことはね
だからそれで心の汚れっていうことが出てきますね
心が怒り 欲 無知で汚れてるんだから
正しくない道は正しく見えるし
正しい道は正しくないと見えるんだよと
だから そもそも道徳の目的っていうのは心を清らかにすることになるんです
心を清らかにするなると
道徳は無効になるんです
道徳の機能は終わりますよと
だから ある一時的 ある一定の時間で人間を育てるための道具に過ぎないんです
道徳は結局 心は完璧に綺麗になったら
人格は完成したらもう道徳一つも犯せません
しかし 道徳守るという気持ちもない
その道徳の狙いっていうのはね
2つあるっていうことも仏教だけの話だと思いますけどね
一つはただ幸福になるっていうことで
もう一つはやっぱり心を育てる
方法の第1ステージ まず規則を守る
道徳論とこの芸っていうのはね
それほど当てはまりませんけど
そちらへ行ってるのは
この 世間のね 価値観よりはね
道徳の価値はすごい優れているんだというね
例えばこのそういうキャラやらね
えっと 船団やらね すごい香りを出す木ですね
あれはね で そういうものっていうのは
俗世間の価値判断でなんて美しい香りでしょうかとか
それよりは道徳的なところの方が素晴らしいと
いうことですから やっぱりまぁ
人間の評価 人間は頭いい人は
し かっこいい人は評価するし
背が高い人は評価するし
いろいろ痩せてる人は評価するし
口が達者人を評価するし
金持ちを評価するしね
そちらにみんな揃っちゃうしね
人気タレントさんだったらサーッと人がそこにもう上がっちゃうし
それでみんな人気タレントになりたがっちゃうしね
ジョン様は神様やと思ってるし
本当にまあすごい世界ですよ
だって観光に行くでしょ
なんか映画撮影した場所に行って写真撮ってとかね
あれ聖地になってるんですね
日本人にとっては それは世間の評価なんですね
だからそれはそういうことに
ことが言いたがっているのは
そういう世間の評価と本当の評価は違いますと
本当に価値あるのは道徳だよと
生命は幸福になるのはそういう道徳な道であって
あの映画撮影した場所に行って写真撮ったんだからといって何の幸福にもなりません
ただ私って世界一バカだよっていう
もう明らかな変わらない証拠を作るだけ
まあ 2つ うん  [紙をめくる音]